foreign
look at what's on the front pages as
they arrive in the next half hour we'll
see what's making the headlines with the
deputy comment editor at the telegraph
Annabelle Denham and the director of the
John Smith Center at the University of
Glasgow Kezia dugdale so let's see
what's on some of those front pages for
you now
I've won a big concession from EU
claimed sunac that's lead on the front
page of the times tomorrow covering
Rishi sunax meeting as we just heard
with EU commission president Ursula
vondeline
The Daily Telegraph is also leading on
the brexit story with the news that Tory
MPS are issuing warnings on the content
of the deal saying it must be put to a
vote
The Daily Mail focuses on Rishi sunak's
new brexit deal with Brussels saying it
may settle the thorny issue of trade
arrangements for Northern Ireland but
could trigger another Tory Civil War
The Daily Express also leads on the
brexit story with Rishi sunax promise
this deal is best for Britain
while the Metro goes with the
possibility of ending this brexit
nightmare over Northern Ireland covering
EU commission president Ursula
vondeline's visit to Britain tomorrow
meanwhile the sun leads on Justice for
Joanna with Dominic Robb promising to
meet the family of hammer attack victim
Joanna Simpson
and the Daily Star leads with what that
Lassie you're nearly extinct the news
that only 500 Collie dogs were born in
the UK last year
and reminded that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and we are joined tonight by the deputy
comment editor at the telegraph
Annabelle Denham and the director of the
John Smith Center at the University of
Glasgow Kezia dugdale welcome to you
both let's start with the Daily Express
seemingly what one story in town on many
of the the front pages and this is this
meeting tomorrow between the Prime
Minister Rishi sunak and as lavonda Lyon
the European commission president in the
hopes of taking the brexit deal the
post-trade brexit deal regarding
Northern Ireland over the line finally
do we think we are there Kezia
yes I think we can be fairly confident
and certainly the prime minister is very
confident that there'll be some sort of
resolution by the end of play tomorrow
been in mind Dominic Rabb was doing the
video around this morning and when he
was asked about the prospect of a date
of a deal he said he thought it would be
days rather than weeks that was very
short-lived answer because it now looks
like a real Act of confidence to have
her still Wonderland on her way to the
United Kingdom to meet with the Prime
Minister tomorrow you've had more
details there from Sam about the
prospect of the cabinet and also the
prospect of a kind of joint Podium press
conference late tomorrow afternoon all
of those details suggest There's real
confidence in their video being done
Annabelle your thoughts do you think as
Kezia does that this is uh we're coming
towards the finish line shall we say
well I mean I think we need to see we
need to see the Braxtons process as
something that is going to be constantly
evolving so whatever details uh come to
light tomorrow we can be fairly
confident that's not going to be the end
of it but certainly it seems like great
leaps have been taken forward and leaps
that we didn't think would be possible
let's not forget that a year or so ago
we didn't believe that you was willing
to come back to negotiating table and I
think it's quite a remarkable feat and
achievement that the Prime Minister has
managed to reopen the question of the
Northern Ireland and protocol and try
and get a better deal particularly for
the people of Northern Ireland this has
been very expensive and damaging to the
Northern Ireland economy not mentioned
the ways in which it's threatened the
stability in the region so you know I
think we're all sitting here on the edge
of our seats hoping that some kind of
arrangement can be arrived at one that
is better than that which Boris Johnson
was able to negotiate when he was prime
minister um interesting to cover the
express there because of course we've
seen that has got to sell it to his own
back Ventures but he's also got to try
and sell this not just to uh the people
of Great Britain but also Ireland and
the European Union to an extent I think
it's certainly in his best interests if
he can can convince us all that this is
indeed uh the best deal that can be
agreed at this time so you know let's
just wait and see because the devil
really will be in the detail yes and
that's exactly what he's doing uh Kezia
by saying that this is the best deal for
Britain
yes that's right and you can do so with
a degree of confidence knowing that the
labor party are very very likely to back
the deal that he's putting forward in
part because they don't want to contest
the next election with brexit still
being a live issue with suitcased armor
a great deal if the whole issue could be
essentially buried and for the
perspectives of the next general
election so he can count on labor votes
there more or less and that means that
the power of the dep the power of those
brexiteers and the Tory benches to
somehow thwart this deal is diminished
then I don't think the threat has
completely gone yet because we haven't
seen the actual detail of the deal we
don't know if it's going to carry just
quite enough support from the
conservatives but like I've said just
the choreography of what's expected to
happen tomorrow suggests that the prime
minister is very confident of being able
to
um secure support from his party
outstanding issue of whether um the
House of Commons will have a vote on the
deal Still Remains it was interesting to
hear politicians in the media around
this morning basically say well I'm sure
the House of Commons will find a way
that seems to suggest that the
government might not orchestrate him a
vote of its own but would be open to
other people trying to create a debate
to change the order of business to allow
for that but it may well be past the
point of no return by the time the House
of Commons gets its act together I think
once you have two leaders standing side
by side at a Podium saying this is as
good as it gets it's time to to move
forward it feels very difficult for
people to stop the process at that point
Annabelle up until this point we've been
led to believe that the gup are not in
favor of a Rishi sunxa and negotiations
and what he he's intending
um that still is that the point tonight
so it's quite a bold move and to be so
confident that a deal might be be sealed
tomorrow when they still don't have the
backing of the the dup
no that's absolutely right of course the
dup have long uh complained about what
they call a democratic deficit this is
essentially the regulatory annexation of
uh Northern Ireland that's created all
of these issues um in in the region um
you know dup uh leader Jeffrey Donaldson
has previously said that the objective
in London and Brussels should be to get
this right rather than rushed he's
concerned that you know the wrong deal
would deepen will further division
rather than uh restore power sharing
um I you know as far as I can tell the
dep are taking a hard line on this but
will be willing to make some uh
concessions so again you know we need to
just see what unfolds uh in the next 24
hours and whether they're going to think
that this is a satisfactory uh solution
but of course you know the fingers have
been burned in the past the Northern
Ireland protocol uh Boris Johnson tried
to insist that there wouldn't be that
border down the rhc well that's exactly
what we've ended up with and look at all
of the issues all of the problems that
that's that's created so you know let's
see what happens and whether it's
something they find palatable moving to
the male Kezia they're reporting that
the European commission is saying that
the meeting will take place in Windsor
and this raises the prospect that Mrs
vonderlein may also hold talks with King
Charles and this is something we
reported on a couple of days ago that
there was a a meeting uh this is a story
that we broke and That Was Then canceled
are you surprised that she might still
be meeting the king
no and I don't think we should worry too
much about this or pay too much kind of
credence if this does happen what it
represents is ceremony what it
represents is courtesy when you have the
president of the European commission
who's literally in Windsor where the
king would be it'll be some hosting odd
I think if they weren't to meet if they
weren't to take that opportunity to
debate about what's been discussed but
yet again it's another aspect of the
choreography that seems to suggest we're
very very close to a deal here I think
it's also interesting looking at the
front page of the Daily Mail to see that
they're kind of hedging their bets it it
you normally would expect the Daily Mail
to sort of tirade against any compromise
on Europe that they didn't to me that
they think it's a done deal too and
they're just putting a little bit of
extra pressure on Richardson act to make
sure that he can sell this deal as the
best possible
um option available to the country
and about what do you make of the
possibility of Ursula vondeline actually
meeting with King Charles might that be
seen as politicizing that the monarchy
or do you think it's just uh normal
courtesy and and uh protocol
well I think in some ways it can be both
we talk a lot you know in politics about
the Optics and I think you know support
from the King as Sky reported you know
would likely be quite controversial it
is going to risk those allegations that
the Monarch is being dragged into
something that is highly uh political
let's not forget uh that the late Queen
faced uh criticism when she took that
step into politics and she suggested
that voters in the Scottish referendum
ought to think very carefully before
they go uh to The Ballot Box and I
imagine that King Charles will have that
in the back of his mind when if indeed
he does have tea with the president of
the European uh commission tomorrow so I
do you know I can I can see that it's a
courtesy I can but I also think that
there's a real risk here that it will be
viewed as the Monarch stepping into very
very political issue let's talk about
the fact that some commentators and the
male is one of those mentioning that um
any deal could trigger another Tori so
Civil War that his own back benches are
probably his his greatest critics in
this and this could really just flare
everything up once again Kezia
listen there are a few key people to
watch in this regard you've already had
Snippets tonight of Mark Francois from
the ERG group saying that as a group
they're not stupid they want to see the
detail of this very closely before they
set out their position but any role
whatsoever of the European Court's still
having I stay over how the protocol
operates would be unpalatable to them so
I think we can anticipate some um some
strong trouble from them in the days
ahead the question is how big are they
how influential are they now how much
could they determine any sort of final
change of track the other person to look
out for is Steve Baker and there's some
really interesting detail in the
telegraph front page with regards to his
role we know that he was invited to
Downing Street today to meet with the
Prime Minister and although he didn't
pass any comment when he came out of the
front door he did give the thumbs up now
that's going to surely the image of that
alone would truly bring me she seem like
even more Comfort to me Annabelle just
uh very quickly in less than than a
minute would you say that his worst
detractors that is Rishi sunaka Within
his own party
yes I think you know let's not forget
that around 24 hours ago that was taught
that Steve Baker was himself on
resignation watch of course Boris
Johnson has let his opposition to a
possible deal uh be known
um I think a lot of the so-called
Spartans
um still worry about what the detail is
going to be and what will the
application of EU law be in Northern
Ireland how far will the concessions on
state aid and vat go will the grace
period stay what will happen to uh Boris
Johnson's Northern Ireland protocol Bill
there are a lot of questions there and I
think you know it's entirely possible
that he doesn't get satisfactory uh they
don't get satisfactory answers then
there could be some kind of conservative
back bench Rebellion I mean about a week
ago there was talk of over a hundred uh
conservative Adventures voting against
it but okay
you raise a lot of questions there that
do need a
welcome back you are watching The Press
preview here on Sky News and back with
me is the Deputy comment editor at the
telegraph Annabelle Denham and the
director of the John Smith Center at the
University of Glasgow Kezia Doug Dale
welcome back to both of you let's um
start by having a look it's covered in a
couple of the papers but we'll start
with the metro and this is this awful
story of the 59 migrants that have been
killed off the coast of southern coast
of Italy
um tragic story bodies being washed up
on shore and dozens more thought to be
missing actually after this disaster
Annabelle
I think Nick no it's our sign I'm
seeking such a political hot potato in
this country and I think sometimes it's
hotly debated and you you forget this or
the human element to it this perilous
Journey that the people take
um to seek Safe Haven
um and you know in this instance
unfortunately some of them haven't made
it at the latest that I read was that at
least 59 migrants including 12 children
uh died dozens more uh feared missing
after their boats sank uh in rough Seas
off uh southern Italy and you know like
I say unfortunately these tragic events
do occur too often hundreds are dying in
the Mediterranean uh every year after
trying to seek uh asylum in Europe and I
think while Rishi sunak is currently
tied up in these brexit negotiations he
also has his Asylum bills pushed through
Parliament at some point in the coming
weeks um to try uh and sort out you know
this thorny and difficult situation that
his predecessors have completely failed
that and that's not just predecessors of
course here in the UK but also European
leaders macron has talked very tough on
uh clamping down on illegal immigration
but has yet to act on on those words
um just as British British leaders have
failed to uh as well so you know let's
see what happens with that in the coming
weeks and and whether we're able to
address it to prevent these stories from
these tragic events from happening in
the future indeed and Kezia the Italian
needed a Georgia Maloney she's vowed a
Crackdown on people smuggling and we
know that at least one person has
already been arrested in Italy
yes and of course she's recently elected
fire Right leader he doesn't take a
particularly um positive view of Asylum
Seekers no matter the horrendous nature
of the circumstances that they've fled
and you look at the images associated
with the story and we're used to seeing
thingies in this channel what this
represents is a wooden boat 170 people
expected to be on this wooden boat from
five days traveling from Turkey to the
southern coast of Italy we know that 80
people have been rescued and as
Annabelle's outlined 58 people declared
dead including every single child on
board we also know that the majority of
the people on this boat came from
Afghanistan Somalia and Pakistan at
least two of those countries you could
describe as War torn people who was you
would expect to have very legitimate
instance your claims for Asylum so I
think once again this is going to put
the issue of how to support people who
are fleeing such Horrors and to make a
better life for themselves right at the
Forefront of our political agenda
and Annabelle just uh quickly the theft
the same story they're they're talking
about an escalating confrontation
between the government the Italian Prime
Minister um as kezi was saying is is
right wing and humanitarian
organizations that carry out the the
rescue missions in the Mediterranean Sea
there's been a distinct Clash
yes there has and I mean look this is
not all together uh surprising that
you're going to see uh ngos who are on
the call Face dealing with these tragic
events uh clashing with uh political
leaders particularly if they're far
right and they're taking a very
unsympathetic view of uh illegal
immigration
um you know that question of of how many
people we we let in
um the idea that we need to clamp down
on on this illegal immigration on Asylum
Seekers coming over not just of course
to Italy but also coming into the UK
it's just this Fierce nasty uh political
debate
um and soon after course like I said you
know it's promising that claims are
going to be heard in a matter of days or
weeks not months and years that failed
applicants will be sent to an
alternative safe country where that'd be
that where they came from or indeed of
course Rwanda
um deporting those who are judged to be
illegible for Asylum again it sounds
like a government that's going to get
tough on this with a view they say 8
trying to ultimately clamp down on
people traffickers
um from the people who are trying to
make a business of really preying on
others misery and their desperation to
flee from their war-torn countries so
you know like I say I I just think this
is going to escalate until the
government uh grafts the nettle and
comes up with some kind of a solution
that is that is reasonable
um
indeed Annabelle and Kezia thank you so
much for taking us through the papers